CBS News is getting an exclusive look at
the National Security Agency's secretive
outpost in the middle of the Pacific
Ocean
it is the first time outside cameras
have been allowed inside
NSA Hawaii is on the front lines of
American intelligence gathering it
intercepts communications and monitors a
region that includes China and North
Korea Carter Evans went to the Hawaiian
island of Oahu to show us how the NSA
protects America around the clock Carter
good morning good morning the NSA is
actually one of 17 US intelligence
agencies and this outpost in Hawaii is
actually one of the particularly busiest
these days as the u.s. shifts its focus
from fighting terrorism to a competition
between nations for critical information
it was also the location where
whistleblower Edward Snowden stole
thousands of classified documents before
he defected to China just beyond this
military checkpoint is the most powerful
surveillance organization in the US and
cameras usually aren't allowed where
we're going this is NSA Hawaii captain
Kurt mole leads the top-secret facility
and took us inside when have you had
civilian cameras in this building before
well this is absolutely a first for me
however we recognize that transparency
breeds trust still we had to blur the
picture here because everything in this
room is classified it's where
specialists listen in on foreign
communications anything that travels
over the radio frequency waves are
inside the electromagnetic spectrum it
can be collected we have the ability to
pull items that have been collected
worldwide much of our reporting even
ends up on the desk of the president the
president has had some harsh words for
the intelligence community what does
that do to morale here nothing we're not
paying attention to that we're focused
on mission what you saw was our 24 by 7
Operations Center there's so much
information coming in though how do you
even begin to sift through it all humans
can only do so much and so we're looking
at ways to where we can utilize a
machine learning to be able to get the
right data to that right analyst can you
talk about any of the successes you've
had I would just offer the Chinese and
their cyber activity is well documented
China wants nothing less than to push
the United States of America from the
western Pacific and much of the
reporting that contributed to US
government actions related to that came
out of this facility over the past 18
months the Trump administration has
slapped Chinese hackers with an
unprecedented number of criminal
indictments after Chinese nationals
attempted to compromise key targets in
the US we're in an office building in a
pineapple field on Oahu but really we're
on the front lines we are on the front
lines Chief Master Sergeant Nina young
controls the NSA teams keeping a close
watch on our adversaries if you look at
just in our own backyard right we have
China and North Korea it's no secret
that they're loud they're noisy they are
willing to use cyber threats and force
you have four of the seven largest world
economies you have seven of the ten
largest militaries five nuclear nations
tell me more about that a cyber power
grab going on it's not just cyber the
United States does not have the
superiority in any of those domains that
we once had deep inside this tunnel is
where the NSA first established a
presence here in Hawaii it's also where
Edward Snowden worked before he stole
hundreds of thousands of classified
documents Snowden was a contractor
working for the NSA Hawaii in 2013 when
he leaked documents outlining American
government surveillance practices is it
something that people here still think
about not at all we don't dwell in the
past our work force our mission is too
critical today what is the NSA's role in
observing American citizens the National
Security Agency in conducting its
missions is always in accordance with
the US law well the domestic phone
surveillance program first exposed by
Snowden is now under review and may be
discontinued still no one at the NSA
would go into any details about the
changes made because it's classified
and I can tell you they are dead serious
about security they comb through all of
our year and no one employees or anyone
else is allowed to bring any electronics
inside of the facility no cell phones no
watches and certainly no USB devices so
I'm curious in why they let you in
there's a there's a couple of reasons
there they're working on their image
right now after the Snowden situation
they want people to know a little bit
more about what they're doing it's also
a recruiting issue because she they're
after the best and brightest tech minds
in the country and they're competing
with companies like Google and Facebook
and they cannot pay what those companies
pay what they can offer though they say
is a fulfilling mission it is
fascinating though for them to allow us
to go a little behind the scenes and
everything blurred there and that was
that the whole room was classified the
whole room was classified I mean
absolutely everything on every screen
was classified that's where they were
listening in to foreign signals
that it's in an old pineapple field yeah
they can't pay the salaries of Google in
the tech giants but they do have that
mission Carter thank you very much
welcome Carter your first time at the
first time at the table yeah thank you